The Dresden stollen originally called
ashed witson is arguably Germany's most
famous Christmas cake it even gave its
name to one of the country's oldest
Christmas markets Dresden streets are
marked
and there's plenty of stolen sampling
among the two and a half million
visitors who come here every winter
it tastes like almonds and raisins all
just right this is Christmas it's a
genuine Dresden stollen good only stolen
baked in the saxon capital and certified
by a special local chapter for quality
control may be called the genuine
dresden variety aroma appearance and
taste all have to meet the high
expectations of the experienced jury
members another criterion is the
proportion of ingredients at least 65%
raisins 50% butter 20% almonds and 20%
orange or lemon zest it were not around
130 companies in dresden may put the
seal of quality on their Storen among
them is the villa bakery a business in
family hands for more than a century
during the holiday season master baker
Michele vipra and his staff turned out
hundreds of stolen every day
vo Gaiden Chi new company make no
compromises for example to adapt the
dough to a machine we use the
highest-quality utensils we've got our
hands leavened dough almonds butter
orange zest lemon zest and raisins these
ingredients are easily obtainable
nowadays but not under the communist
regime of East Germany lemon zest had to
be imported from abroad plus the
centralized government planners
allocated the precious commodity mostly
to state combines not small bakeries the
bakers had to improvise
- Key Club of the Queen - mod we got the
idea of using unripe green tomatoes
which don't actually have much taste on
their own but they're green like lemon
zest
we candid them and try to dice them
which met with limited success but we
had to try green tomatoes instead of
lemon zest because the zest was in short
supply hello bake in the oven for an
hour and cool overnight then they're
slathered with butter and sprinkled with
plenty of powdered sugar
- : symbology us in vigilance symbolizes
the baby Jesus in swaddling clothes
which are white that's why the stolen
are sprinkled with sugar
more than three million stolen with the
seal of quality are baked interest in
every holiday season about one in four
are exported to the rest of Europe and
overseas The Dresden Christmas stollen
even as its own spokeswoman the stolen
girl she's entrusted with passing on the
pastries tradition
The Dresden Christmas stollen originated
in monastery bakeries it was first
mentioned in writing in 1471 back then
it was just a simple bread made of flour
water and yeast at first the church
wouldn't allow the use of butter then in
1491 the Pope rescinded the ban in his
famous butter letter so the stolen girl
is also promoting extra calories that
shouldn't be hard I think it's very
delicious it's not too sweet I came all
the way from South Africa just to taste
the genuine original stolen I really
like it's now in the Christmas spirit
Dresden a Christian may be easier to
swallow them to pronounce is not custard
this is the story
it is Christmas tour
and to wash down a genuine Dresden
stollen at the streets all marked
there's no shortage of a suitable
beverage mulled wine a very popular
combination during the holiday season